hey everyone devolo here and in today's
video we will be going over one of the
very best characters and one of the few
people takamichi can tell absolutely
anything about at any moment without
being afraid of any kind of
repercussions this here is no one other
than the vice president of the insanely
durable first division under hanagaki
our best boy shifu matsuno i absolutely
love shifuyu and i definitely think his
character throughout the story has been
written almost perfectly honestly him
and takamichi have some of the greatest
moments i've ever read in manga so i
can't wait to get into this video today
but just before we do make sure you all
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like if you do enjoy my
content as it really helps out with that
silly youtube algorithm plus i've also
got a discord if you guys are interested
and want to recommend me something to
read for in the up and coming future or
just a possible video idea that i could
uh put out to you guys later on as it
all really just helps out but anyway
enough of that let's get into the best
supporting character in the entire tokyo
avengers story
p.s
i'm sorry bhaji i didn't mean it so who
really even is shifu matsuno well
shifuyu is a young man of average height
with light blue eyes light skin and a
piercing in his left ear he's a major
supporting character who was the vice
captain of takamichi's first division
but in all honesty i think the official
character book answers who he is
perfectly one of the last questions
asked throughout the official character
book was who would you want as your
subordinate with the answer being
shifuyu and not just for any odd reason
is our boy he will be your best friend
and strive to do the best for you even
if you're not wanting him to as evident
with how he was trying to save the goat
bhaji during the valhalla arc this man
will never falter or leave your side he
is willing to let his emotions take
control when a situation calls for it
and will never shy away from helping
others out even if he gets beaten up by
or for his friends he sticks by their
sides
but before all of this during his first
year of middle school he was slightly
different he was regarded as an infamous
punk students followed him around
commenting on how badass he was and how
he had the strength to rule japan
though this began to change once he met
the goat bhaji who had actually been
held back a year one day when shifuyu
was heading home he got ambushed and
stopped by a biker gang because he had
beaten up one of their members during
school the biker gang started to fight
shifuyu while he was by himself which
resulted in him getting completely
overwhelmed by the sheer numbers of
members fighting against him luckily
before it was too late baji showed up
and completely decimated the rest of the
members all by himself he then declared
himself as a captain of tomen and stated
that shifuyu is his friend he then
invited shifuyu to eat peyongyaki soba
with him splitting it when there was
only one bowl left as we know from the
valhalla incident and the last thing
that baji ever said to shifuyu which was
that he wanted to go and get yaki sober
this must have been an extremely
influential moment in shifuyu's life as
why else would baji have brought it up
on his deathbed it must have been the
moment that shifu looked back on as the
time he decided to follow bhaji and
become his best friend as i'm guessing
that no one else had ever stood up for
shifu in the past which is obviously
something that means a lot to him as
it's exactly what takamichi does as well
and wajifuyu ends up becoming such a
good friend to him because he stood up
for bhaji and tried his hardest to save
his life during his time in turmon he
typically acted as an adviser of
takamichi and made plans before the
group would decide on what they were
going to do not that the plans usually
ever go to plan but well i guess that's
just anime in general he is usually
super composed under high pressure
situations that might even cost him his
life though he acts knowledgeable and
level-headed he is naive at times and
doesn't always plan things meticulously
which has led to unfortunate
consequences at times like with how he
ended up in a weird role play situation
with kisaki and hanma getting tied up
and left in a room all the while
takamichi was left to pretty much face
down the monster taiju alone takamichi
also trusts our boy so much that he even
let slip that he was actually able to
time travel back and forth 12 years to
the day along with his experiences up
until that point which is something that
not a single character other than naoto
up until that point in the story
actually knew
in reaction to takamichi's confession he
also confessed to him that somehow he
always knew takamichi was a time
traveler and commends him for trying to
help everyone then in a way that will
always bring a tear to my eye and warms
my heart he tells takamichi that he will
always have his back which is something
that he has always lived by since that
day
when it comes to shifuyu's strength and
fighting skills it's never said if he
specifically knows any kind of
techniques but even as a middle schooler
he was strong enough to run his entire
school basing up the older students with
ease as the series progresses his
strength never seems to drop as well he
is always a formidable fighter who will
usually take on a few fodder delinquents
at once and even fight against the
leaders of other divisions and other
gangs though he is not among the
strongest fighters in the series his
fighting prowess is not to be
underestimated so a little bit of a
shorter video today but that brings us
to really the end of what we know about
shifuyu matsuno and even though he
doesn't really play a huge part until
partway through the valhalla arc from
that point onwards he was a key member
of the story who you would constantly
want to see more of if you want me to go
over all of the tokyo avengers
characters one by one then be sure to
let me know down in the comment section
below or go over to my discord and let
me know who you think i should go over
in the next video if you have enjoyed
this video though and want to watch
other ones just like it then do be sure
to hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i will see you
all and a bird
bye
[Music]
you